improve communication is the goal in
high level talks this weekend between
U.S and Chinese officials Secretary of
State Anthony blinken departed for
Beijing overnight he is the highest
ranking member of the Biden
Administration to travel to China and
he's the first Secretary of State to
travel there since 2018 but blinken's
visit comes at a time when relations
between the U.S and China are very
strained CBS News Chief Foreign Affairs
correspondent and Face the Nation
moderator Margaret Brennan as a preview
the expectations are low but the stakes
are quite high as the U.S launches an
intense diplomatic push to keep
competition from escalating into
conflict
intense competition requires sustained
diplomacy to ensure that competition
does not Veer into confrontation or
conflict secretary blinken's mission is
to avoid veering into direct conflict
with China he suddenly called up a trip
in February after a Chinese spy balloon
was spotted then shot down in American
airspace since then China's military has
pulled off what the U.S has called
unnecessarily aggressive tactics two
close calls one in the South China Sea
with a fighter jet and another in the
Taiwan Strait with a warship President
Biden has largely continued the
direction of the trump-era policies both
accuse China of economic coercion
alleged that Beijing did not share
information about the first covid
outbreak and denounced that communist
party's human rights abuses including
genocide against Muslim minorities the
bind Administration says it is now
focused on managing the risk of
escalation I think you're going to see
that begin to thaw very sure
caught in the middle three American
prisoners held on what the U.S believes
are trumped-up charges 48-year-old Texan
Mark swedon was sentenced to death
67-year-old Pastor David Lynn arrested
in 2006 and 59-year-old Kai Lee taken at
the Shanghai airport in 2016 after
flying in for his mother's memorial
service my dad is an innocent American
who's being being wrongfully entertained
and you know our government has failed
for you know almost seven years now
across three administrations to bring
him home Harrison Lee said his father is
kept in a small crowded cell and
permitted to call home twice a month for
just seven and a half minutes we just
need you President Biden to use all
tools cut through the bureaucratic noise
do what you can to just bring my dad
home secretary blinken said he will make
an in-person appeal on behalf of all
three prisoners and Harrison told us he
hopes that will help free his dad to
date none of the talks with Chinese
officials have made clear whether
Beijing is open to a prisoner trade or
what it will take to secure their
release
for CBS Saturday morning Margaret
Brennan Washington
and Margaret will be reporting from
Beijing tomorrow morning on
Face the Nation